i've hired me i've literally just sold
i've saved
the world in the last 30 seconds yeah
that's it
welcome guys we're back with a bang oh
god he drops his phone it happens
it happens we move we move is that how
it's not how you drop it it's how you
recover
from the drop well then once there you
know them once
um so nice to see you to see you nice
we're back in full effect
sng shits and gigs fandom mandem hope
you guys are good
monday fun day what are you saying what
are you saying james
bro i'm i'm saying some good [ __ ] you
know yeah we love to hear and we love to
see you guys i've got a red monster in
my hand
and some funny thoughts on my head good
it's the best way to start the day mum
best way to start the day um okay
cool well so
guys i feel like you're going to see
that stupid
i quit my job do you know
the funny thing about that is obviously
you told me a time ago but i forgot
you've not mentioned it i completely
forgot you've not mentioned it
guys i'll quit my job say it again for
the people involved guys
i quit my job
fam everyone take five seconds just give
it a round of applause because we know
we all know as a community how long this
my man has been complaining about his
job
and we know how much we all wanted him
to leave his job
he's finally there guys guys i finally
quit my job he finally quit his job
i did it i [ __ ] quit it was so gassed
when you told me oh i know i was
petrified music i found something to
tell you i was like
oh my god what bro i was petrified
i was excited to tell you but i was
scared because then i thought once i
tell you that means it's real
real yeah not my time manager i want to
tell flakes when i tell you it's real
of course so yeah guys i've done it um
so
the podcast is gonna be way better now
way better i know you like it how it is
but it's going to be way better now
there's going to be more content for you
guys
um in terms of just like little little
hits and then i'm not going to give too
much away but there's there's a few
things that me and throughout the
cooking
um for you guys that we just never had
the time to do yeah and now we have that
well at least i do anyway have the time
to to get it
to get produced for you guys so it's
gonna take off now
so buckle up strap in guys strap in uh
buckle up it's gonna about to take off
um and but yeah um this is about giving
thanks so guys this is all thanks to you
so this moaning that i've been doing for
like the last year and a half has
finally paid off
um and yeah bro i quit i quit
i quit um i no longer have an office job
going and i quit and now i uh a podcast
full time
okay so yeah it feels weird saying that
out loud
it's surreal in it surreal very surreal
so yeah that's that
that's just that good quit i'm so happy
for you brother thank you bro hold this
blood
i'm going to quit soon guys don't worry
yeah face is going to quite come in my
time is coming
but it's just not there yet but we're
moving it's not um that's all thanks to
you guys
appreciate you massively
i feel like i can breathe i feel like a
fat cow's just got off my chest
i feel like i can breathe that's
hilarious um
so yeah guys that's that um
shit's gonna get better um that being
said
i did quit but i'm still poor
i quit with just like i said when the
when
when we make just a penny enough that i
can quit i will and i did
but it means i'm broke yeah he's like
found these grounds
bro i'm ground zero now i'm a starving
artist
so you man are gonna have to influx the
patreon just to keep my head above water
i'm doing this for you lot i'm doing
this for you lot so please do this for
me yeah yeah yeah
three pound a month 10p a day run me
come on now you know no more time
uh you know the score you know the vibe
onto the fun facts
of course um bretta just messaged us
again saying it happened
in eight minutes 50 seconds to 10
minutes the buff printing
on the new year's episode cool there's
nothing i could do about it i know i'm
just like you know
and did you put it on someone else
emailed us saying did you put it on
patreon it's like oh where's the video
for the link for this week
uh i didn't have i didn't put it on
patreon okay just updated enough time
cool anyway
um so did you know to be fair
maybe you might know i don't know but i
never knew this the singer marvin gaye
was shot and killed by his
own father the day before his birthday
no i didn't know that his father used
the gun that marvin had gifted him
that's the facts and i'll give you the
detail
so gay marvin marvin gay gay
um intervened a fight between his
parents on the afternoon of the 1st of
april
1984 in his family home in west adams
district
in la and and he became involved in a
physical altercation with his father
marvin gaye senior who gave shot twice
once in the chest
piercing his heart and then gay's
shoulder the shooting took place in
gay's bedroom
in 12 at 12 38 p.m the first shot proved
fatal
so gay junior obviously marvin gaye was
pronounced dead
at 101 pm after his body was arrived at
the hospital
a day short from his 45th birthday after
gay's funeral his body was cremated
his ashes were scattered to the ocean
gay senior was initially charged with
first-degree murder
but the charges were reduced to
voluntary manslaughter following a
diagnosis of his brain tumor he was
given a suspended six-year sentence and
probation
he died in a nursing home in 1998
wow bro
imagine your father killing you from a
with a gun that you gifted him
first why did he buy his dad a gun i
don't know it was a different gift it
was a difference
it was a different time before i wasn't
born yeah true
that's crazy though i never knew that
dad's a psychopath
shot him twice during the old case so
marvin gaye junior
tried to stop the beaver team not leave
her alone leave her alone
my
one in the chest one in the shoulder my
son
marvin gaye you know he brings in all
the money sexual healing
when i get that feeling nah he brought
in all the pee and he just dumped
it he just let off two rounds in his
chest
that is wow that is
wow indeed i don't really have anything
to say
it's mind blowing in it yeah it's so
crazy i had no
idea that i had no idea
wow i don't even know that's how he died
bro saying let alone his dad killed him
same i've never even thought about how
he died i just thought it was he just
died being old or something i don't even
know
it didn't cross my mind wow but yeah
that's that's
crazy the fun fact of the day jesus
christ it is um it's a bit of a gruesome
fact but it's still a fact
you know wow i never knew that happened
i'm pretty sure
well we'll see if a lot of people didn't
know or didn't know but we'll see
it's crazy jesus crazy fact okay cool
right what you got for would you rather
love these
let's give it a go this is dumb this is
just like a childish one
but [ __ ] it would you rather fight a
bear or a shark
it reminds us so i will answer the
question but it reminded me of an
episode again
i was watching american dad and it was
the episode where
steve has an uncontrolling fear of
sharks
yeah he reminded me of you because you
hate sharks oh my god yeah
and i think it's where um stan asked his
dad to
stan asked steve to come in the ocean to
do um what's the thing where
you've got the jets on your feet and it
shoots you up like hoverboard hoverboard
steve is like i'm not about it i'm not
getting in the water bro
i'm just not man was on a beach in a
full white thing with like a mosquito
net on his head
i don't even like the sand let alone the
wall i'm not doing it
so roger being roger was like oh the
best way for you to face your fears is
to be forced into it
yeah so roger plays the roger plays
the shark and then stan
stan dashes him into the ocean yes
that's the typical [ __ ]
he's flapping obviously man's coming
through coming through coming through
and he smacks the um shark on effect
well the shark is roger
smacks him on the nose and then
obviously swims away
and then um stan picks him up and i was
like oh my god you fought the thing bro
smith smith what's his name steve is so
gassed yeah
he's like i can't believe i just did
this he gets so gas he starts abusing
the shark of course he does and roger's
right there and raises like this
[ __ ] [ __ ] little shark i beat
the [ __ ] out of it oh my god i'm never
gonna be afraid again
so as roger's hearing this as the shark
steve puts his hand in the air like a
triumphant fist
roger scoops up and bites his arm off
he's like you mother
he he ripped his arm off he
ripped his phantom oh my blood that
spewed
a man just you know stevie's dramatic
yeah he collapsed like
he collapsed in steve's arms it stands
on i'm sorry oh it was so funny
as you need to say that's what you're
right but
i feel like the only reason why i would
choose a bear is because of the land
advantage yeah i can't swim and fight a
shark
it's impossible no one can no one can no
one can it's impossible i'm dying both
ways yeah yeah but i feel like i've got
i would last probably like 10 seconds
longer
online i promise you now i'm not dealing
with a shark i know i know you're not
not
dealing with it i wouldn't want to deal
with a bear but i'm a million percent
not dealing with a shark a million i'm
not
dealing with a show i know but they're
they're they're dinosaurs
they're terrified they're creatures
absolutely terrifying
i can't think of anything scarier they
look they
they don't seem like they should exist
they seem like something that you could
make up
in a horror movie that we have so many
horror movies about sharks
because they're a real life monster they
are
a real life monster and you don't have
to make any adaptations to make the
shark scary than it already [ __ ] is
yeah
it's a thing that when you're in this
[ __ ]
ocean yeah and you can barely move and
you're like yeah yeah
there's something in there that can go
and just scoop you yam you
quick it's got hundreds of teeth
it will back you it's done i watched a
shark movie not long ago
what was it i watched a shark movie not
long ago is it meg
nah not that i'm not i'm not because you
see the student session i think it was
called like
i think it's called like open water or
something like that okay it's basically
a girl
she goes to mexico she loves surfing she
goes all the way to this like private
beach in mexico
no one there it's lavish the weather's
supposed to be kicking
so she finds a way there she has to go
through like a jungle everything yeah
get a tour guide to get to this beach
finally gets there
go surfing there's only like two other
mexican dons there
and as she's there she sees
she's like obviously surf and surface
and her day's done she's chilling ready
to go
she sees like a whale corpse just
floating on the water like
in the deep bit she's like oh [ __ ] fam
as she looks over
there's a shark back in it a great whale
great white backing the the blubber
off the table she's like oh my [ __ ]
god
bro my man clocks her
and just and he's on he wants to yam her
fam
he doesn't know there's a whale there
anymore he doesn't care
he's adamant he wants to back her bro
bro so she has to she's paddling
paddling paddling my man knocks her off
the board
she manages to swim to like this tiny
little rocky
island in the middle of the ocean and
she's stuck there
my man's just circling it's a tiny
mattress
oh i don't know some blonde yeah okay um
because it sounds like it sounds
like i've seen the trailer before is it
ryan reynolds misses
yes it is yeah i've seen the trailer
i've never watched this movie i've seen
it i completely forgot it is her yeah
yeah yeah yeah serena
would you say yeah yeah yeah yeah gossip
girl xoxo yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah um so yeah playing lively yeah yeah
yeah
yeah it was she goes through it she's
there for
days because it's a private beach yeah
but the tide comes up as well oh
stress bro it's so stressful does every
time she have she puts her foot in there
bro the shark's on it and she's got like
this massive gash down her leg
so the blood is the blood's just
dripping in the thing he's hungry for
her
the whole movie is just her just
chilling and then there's people that
come on the beach now and again she's
screaming for them bro
screaming but and the two dogs that she
saw the day before they come back
they get in the water and she's like get
out
she they they're too far to even
understand what she's saying they're
just like oh there's that ting from
yesterday and they're like yeah yeah
yeah i found the shark
backs them backsome there's a backside
i'm not [ __ ] with a shark never in a
million years
and i hate when people are like oh yeah
but they don't really like the taste of
shut up you don't know what they like
the taste of yeah
and bro i don't like the taste of
certain [ __ ] until i'm hungry enough
yeah
true so true if donnie hasn't eaten in a
couple days
he'll back me anything i don't want to
he doesn't like the taste
i don't want to hear it god but bear
will
ah a bear will snap your neck
so one bro one bang in your head is gone
i'm not fighting you can't fight that
you honestly can't fight it's not a
fight
yeah it's not a fight it's just suicide
if jake was here he'd say different
of course but jake would probably
probably think he could scrap a shark as
well of course he can he can't even swim
he can't he thinks he's see uh he
stresses me out but anyway he thinks
it's above everything it's a lose-lose
but i'd probably pick the bear as well
because yeah because like you could at
least run
for how long yeah i know i know that's
what i said that's why i said i'd last
ten seconds long bro that's the thing
like
you can at least run in the hope that he
might twist his ankle or something
he might get shin splints yeah satin
might happen in this little run that i
get away from him
and i can like duck and die yeah yeah
yeah i just feel like they're like
a jar fam just spin it spin move
just to get away from it but yeah the
shark will just finish you
instantly instantly bro the thing as
well i don't know why this doesn't get
talked about probably because they don't
i don't think there's ever been
like a registered attack on humans but
killer whales
others i find even scarier than sharks
okay
bro they they are the meanest
[ __ ] going
have you seen how they just play with
their food yeah i've seen on david
attenborough as soon as you said killer
balls there's one where i think they're
chasing a a sea otter or chasing a seal
or something like that
they just dash it a bit time they flick
it up and play catch
yeah yeah yeah i've seen it they don't
have no respect they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah they're the deadliest thing i can
imagine they're dangerous as well
orcas i think they're all the same thing
yeah yeah same thing
yeah um yeah bro they're they're
incredibly scary
they're basically sharks they're
humongous sharks i could never
that's what i'm saying i couldn't i
couldn't kayak i couldn't surfboard i
couldn't do any because i'm not seeing
any of these
oh now bro every time i've been i've
decided
thinking about it now i don't actually
think i'll ever be in the ocean again in
my life
i just don't think i just i just don't
see it happening yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
even even if you like go to a beach and
like the front bit like this yeah
our piddle paddle yeah this thing yeah
yeah yeah and you know when like the
the tide goes out and you run in and it
comes back you like you run you don't
act like a little kid you're such a yeah
i'll do them things there but if
anyone's even like jet skiing i'd what
i'd love to do jet skiing
or like even just like um water skiing
or something like that i'd love to do
all them things but then
as soon as i'm in the deep yes when the
water gets cold cold
that's when you know bro we and my dad
were in grenada
a few years ago and we went kayaking and
it was like we got like one of them two
seater ones it was him in the front me
in the back
first of all hardest thing on your
shoulders it destroys your shoulders bro
i can imagine this imagine this thing oh
my god
it's been a workout you must the next
thing when you work you must not be able
to
oh bro my shoulders were frozen yeah
like i couldn't move my arms the next
day i don't know how people do that for
a living
or just for as a hobby bro like
literally like two minutes and i was
like
wow wow damn this is awful
um but anyway yeah yeah
kayaking grader having a good time and
then all it takes is like
with my paranoia of the ocean all it
takes is a small little seed
all it takes is a small small small
little seed someone just has to make a
joke
or anything and then i remember sitting
there and then we paused it was like
sunset and it was this beautiful moment
just chilling in this island in this
nice water
and then just the sunset in and then you
look over and you can see our resort on
the beach and you're just like wow this
is the life
yeah and then just this tiny little seed
in my head was just like
i wonder what's below us and then that
was enough for me i was a panic attack
immediate panic attack where i'm just
like get me the [ __ ] out of here
get me the water's too warm dad the
creatures love it here i know they do no
one can tell me any different
get us back i'm so scared get us back
oh that's hilarious but i'm tired of
it's always like
i don't like people following trends not
trains but like when people
are like oh like i remember we were in
spain and i think i might have said the
story around here before actually but we
were in spain
and we went banana boating and stuff and
then i fell off the back of the banana
boat brings about and i was
piddling there waiting to get picked up
and i looked down couldn't see nothing
yeah yeah yeah i was like i'm gonna die
yeah yeah oh there's no sharks here i'm
just like you don't
know that you can't know that
i'm so tired of these accusations these
false statements they don't like humans
they're not in this region like shut up
you don't know that you don't know that
you don't know what these men can do
yeah they do what they want they don't
follow your rules bro they don't follow
your rules or your trends
they do what they want so yeah i'm never
uh i'm i'm
i'm 99 certain i'll never be in the
ocean again as long as i live was
grenada post or pre-spain
oh post so was grenada the last time you
went in the ocean
to your recollection have i been in the
ocean
well we didn't go in the ocean and i
beef or did we no
yeah i don't think i've been in the
ocean since i went to grenada and that
was
four or five years ago i can't think of
a single time i've been in the ocean
since then
and i don't think i'll ever be in there
again i can't remember sometimes in the
ocean
it's a it's a death trap it's a death
sentence it is a death sentence
get out of there um as usual guys real
quick
manscaped as a today sponsor man escape
to today's sponsor
um as per guys you know the draw by now
we're not gonna give you the whole song
and dance bro if you want clean
fresh-smelling moisturized gleaming
balls
which literally everyone does every guy
would want then the code is sng
mousegate.com 20 off free shipping
jump in sort the ting and let the
streets know let the streets know
because the gal want fresh saving bulls
they wanna when they
it's going to be clean bro they don't
want to be flossing
yeah they don't want none of that they
just want a quick and it just slides out
like a hard-boiled egg
that's hilarious so yeah guys jump in uh
ladies again as well
jump in for your man this is more
important for you ladies because
your man's just not going to get up and
do it himself he needs to be encouraged
this is a great gift for him it the the
packaging itself is beautiful
it's something it's actually one of the
most impressive packaging i've ever seen
it's incredible
um so yeah guys jump in as i said my
skate.com
discount code is sng 20 off from free
shopping
yeah go over there today and uh line our
pockets nice did you ever watch that
have you watched that see spirit seating
yet
no i'm not have you seen it good i
haven't seen all of it
is it one episode thing was an episode
good question
i can't remember now i think it's one
episode
maybe not i can't remember it doesn't
yeah i can't remember but anyway
bro bro
really cause then okay hit me hit me
hear me obviously the name is
trash yeah they should have called it
because conspiracy right yeah
it's just it's just such a no-brainer it
it oh
it's frustrating yeah anyway
[Music]
um i'm still i'm gonna watch it so it's
all about obviously like the fishing
industry
i remember the trailer so the guy
there's basically like this illegal
fishing rink
like shark hunting rink in uh no dolphin
oh oh my god in japan the japanese man
don't give a [ __ ]
they do not give a [ __ ]
about life about like
the ecosystem they don't care bro
they get these fishing boats right
with like a net in between all of them
and they force
these dolphins into like a little cove
so they're just bare dolphins like
tossing around like in this
small little enclosed area so then they
get these these divers to jump in
and they just start killing dolphins and
taking them
and um what they do is
for the ones that they're not even using
no no no they don't kill them they
capture them
and then send them off they get paid to
send them to like these wildlife
like sea centers where they do backflips
and [ __ ] that's how they get them
people just capture them and take them
but the ones that they don't take they
don't even let go back
out they kill them jesus
because they don't want the dolphins
eating the fish when they go fishing
they see dolphins as like um competitors
whatever so just kill dolphins bro
they just stab them up in the ocean in
the ocean
but the blood those about blood from
these dolphins in this
shot is the whole ocean is blood red
they're just shanking up these dolphins
bruv
jesus and the guy who's filming it is
like what the [ __ ] am i looking at yeah
i can imagine
and then um i can imagine the shark fin
you know they're like their shark fin
soup over there yeah apparently shark
feeds the soup tastes like [ __ ]
no one likes it but it's just like a
status thing because it cost a bomb yeah
bro
there's a camera there like a scuba like
a camera go on the
the base of the across japan across like
the sea floor
corpses of just um sharks with no top
fin
dead sharks are just just no top fin
hundreds of them
hundreds of the ocean bed
and the the juiciest of it the juiciest
of it
is like so you know when um like
dolphin-safe tuna
so the tins are tuna they've got like
the dolphin safety
um with the dolphin safe tuna
obviously that's to prove that when
they're hunting for hunting for dolphins
et cetera et cetera
you know hunt for tuna they don't
accidentally catch
a dolphin and grind it up and mix it in
the tuna
so he goes to the company who makes like
the dolphin safe
tuna logo and says like how do you
what's the process to make sure that
there's no dolphins going in there
man basically turned around and was like
there isn't one
he's like so how do you know that
there's no dolphins in there and he said
we don't and then he said
so how do people get dolphin safe tuna
then
and he's like well sometimes we send out
like observationists
on the fishing boats to make sure
there's no dolphins getting captured he
said how often do you do that and he's
like
really he was so honest it was scary did
you know he was being recorded
oh yeah he was an interview oh he was
mic'd up everything oh man
i said really and then the guy was like
what he was like yeah rarely because um
for the people that were because people
can't sell
these this day and age the the fishers
the fishermen can't sell their tuna
without a dolphin-safe
tuna um approval okay
so they can't sell their tuna so
they'll just bribe the guy the
observation is just on the boat they'll
just bribe him
and if he doesn't take the bribe they'll
just kill him bro there was
stories buried stories of people getting
chucked over
fishing boats the observations that
worked for the dolphin safe trading
place that wouldn't take the bribe they
just got talked overboard
bro i was like what and then
um so with these people that are like um
for people that are like uh would you
say like like greenhouse gas
and all this stuff and like um you know
like pollution in the ocean
so apparently our oceans are dry fam
oceans are dry there's hardly any
[ __ ] fish there
okay so much overfishing there's so much
pollution so you know this whole like
uh you know the whole like plastic
straws and all this stuff get rid of
plastic straws and all this stuff
bro so basically he was investigating he
was like oh what like what's the
percentage of like obviously
we need to clean up the oceans we need
to clean up the beaches and all this
little stuff like what
can we do yeah and one guy was like
bro literally like eighty percent i
can't remember the actual percentage was
[ __ ] ridiculous like 80
no no no it was uh more than 50 percent
i think it was like 52 of all of the
litter in the ocean or all the plastic
in the ocean
is discarded fishing nets so when these
men are done with the fishing is to just
cut it off the boat and leave it there
so the guy went to these people who like
do this like oh get rid of plastic
straws they kill in the oceans and stuff
like that he went to the museum i can't
find anything on your website that says
about the fishing nets
like it's like 50 it's like the vast
majority why does it say anything about
the fishing nets
um they were acting different bro
when he was asking these kind of
questions they were acting different
different and then they were saying they
also promote there's other companies
that also promote
like um like to to help
the um
to help to help prevent the seas from
drying up from overfishing
they have like bio something i can't
remember the terminology but basically
regenerative
fish so fish that's not endangered and
fish that like
when you're eating it like something
something i can't even remember but
basically like
eat fish from like farms where they're
forcing breeding and stuff like that so
that you can just like
we're not gonna run out kind of thing um
and so he looked into it more and it was
like oh okay cool so i'm looking all
this all this
and the stats are showing me that like
if we keep eating fish the way we're
eating fish now
like we're gonna have no fish left in
the next like
50 years if we have no fish left that
the and the oceans are dead
there's no coral there's no nothing like
the whole world will die
basically without fish the whole world
will die um
there's just not gonna be any fish left
so he was talking to one of those ladies
that's like um
obviously um talking about like survival
of the fish and all this stuff and
helping seasons like
wouldn't it make more sense to just
encourage people to eat less fish
to help with this you guys like i've
looked on all your
your interviews and all of you like
websites and all this stuff and not one
point does it ever say just
eat less [ __ ] fish and then the late
the
like the vice president or whatever he's
talking to she was like oh
she feels awkward bro she's on the spot
she was um well i mean
yeah i guess like you could just kind of
like try and stop eating fish and stuff
like that that would help and he's like
all right gang
he said yeah but you'd have to talk to
like tracy about that like tracy's the
president like
she'd be the better person to talk to so
he went to go chat to tracy and was like
oh
your colleague said if we just stop
eating fish then it would probably be
the biggest help so i'm just wondering
why that's not on the website
yeah and she was like i promise you now
she never said don't eat fish
and mom was like big man i interviewed
her she said don't eat fish
she agreed with me and he was like she
was like oh i i'll bet my life on it she
didn't say that
and he was like bet gee she did say it
yeah i've got it on camera she said it
yeah and then they did a little rewind
clip of the woman actually saying it
um and she was like no no no like that's
not that's not the best move and he's
like but it obviously is like
why are you saying that like what
interest is it of yours
like you're saying you want to save the
oceans but you're not telling people to
eat less fish like
what i don't understand this and then
she was just like
i'm locking the interview now like get
out like i don't want to do this anymore
to
drape the mic off to get out bro he did
the investigations of who
owns these companies so the companies
that are all about cleaning up the ocean
the companies that's all about like save
the fish
all these come to the dolphin safe tuner
all this stuff
from they're all owned by fisher
companies
all of them are owned by fishing
companies jesus
so the fishing companies are causing the
problem and they own the companies
they're trying to solve the problem
but obviously they can't say that the
fishing is the problem yeah
the fishing is the problem so they have
to come up with all these [ __ ]
little
straws of the problem [ __ ] um
like biorestainable [ __ ] fish is is
not used by
like reusable fish or whatever it's like
is the problem like fishing is a problem
but none of them are allowed to say
fishing is a problem because they're
[ __ ] owned by fishing companies
the man said i can bet my life initially
fishing's the problem
bro that's shady [ __ ] man
the documentary is crazy shady [ __ ]
crazy
i'm going to watch it i wanted to watch
it when it came out but the title vexed
me yeah the title
as well well i've always heard not
good things about it but i've heard it's
very interesting oh bro it's super
interesting it's just the cover-ups are
crazy i can imagine and there's so much
and like he said like especially like
japan and like asian stuff like that
like the fishing industry is like
directly involved with like
mob activity and like the yakuza and
stuff like you just can't [ __ ] with the
fish
fishermen they do what they want really
bro they make so much money from fishing
it's all it's
crazy it's crazy you know bro
i [ __ ] hate fish i don't [ __ ] i
like a cheeky bit of salmon nagiri now
when i get it i'm not gonna lie to you
i'm only a tuna and a salmon guys i like
tuna as well yeah and a bit of salmon
but yeah i don't even [ __ ] with fish at
all but bro when i as soon as i thought
about it
i went to sainsbury's the next day and
you know they've got the fresh fish
aisle
and they're just bare fish all over the
ting
and you're like they're going to chuck
all of that away no one's buying that
and then you go through like the aisle
and there's just fish fish fish fish
fish fish fish fish
everywhere and you're like [ __ ] like
this is all gonna get thrown away
and then just i'm thinking [ __ ] hell
like how many fish are people
how much fish are we like because this
is the difference between like fishing
and like
factory farming and stuff like that
stuff with the farm in is we're not
going around the world
like hunting animals and dragging them
so that the world has no more animals
it's like we are actually making the
animals and then killing them i don't
agree with it
but that's what's happening so we're not
running out of animals because we just
keep making more animals
whereas the fishing we don't breed fish
we just go out and fish
and we just take them all and bro they
was in the numbers between
i think there was a stat i'm gonna
butcher this but it's just like an
example
one apparently something like one i
think it was like
not even that long ago like between 30
and 50 years ago
yeah one fishing boat would be able to
catch like four tons worth of fish in a
day
now an entire like fishing fleet
will catch like four tons in one day
the amount one fishing boat used to do
like 40 years ago
it takes like 10 to do now because
there's [ __ ] all fish in the ocean bro
there's [ __ ] all there wow it's scary
i like the time frames is like in like
10 years
there's got to be nothing yeah i was
when you started this conversation
about the c spirit c i was thinking
there's probably not going to be enough
fish left
after bro then literally the time frames
are like it's literally like 10 years
before there's nothing these might need
to lock off fishing
i don't give a [ __ ] about fishing lock
it
i don't care locking we need to save the
world man bro let's save the world
first let's fish later we'll come back
to that i'm willing to cut sushi out for
a few years to just bring these man back
oh my gosh because they could probably
replenish their their things in like a
couple years
of course fish lay eggs fam
thousands of them just take a year off
chill
just chill chill for a bit that's all to
say that let's take it but maybe
every once every 10 years we just take a
year off fish just like lent
in it let's just let's just take some
time off fish
and then yes the fishing industry will
crumble but that's their business
they'll be fine they'll be fine yeah man
if the whole world came together if
they're like the
like um what's that world organization
called
what world health organization not the
world health organization just like the
like obviously like you know like the
european union what's the world what's
the global one of that
i can't remember what it's called no
united nations
okay so united nations the united
nations was just like cool
let's all agree that once every 10 years
we're going to stop
fishing for a year and then all of the
countries in the united nations
will we're going to have a designated
fund
to fund the fishing industry for one
year every 10 years
and that's just what we're going to do
so they won't get bankrupt and blah blah
blah yeah so they're just
they can still [ __ ] with their money
yeah makes sense and then the fishing
industry as a whole would have to take a
10 hit
for the next 10 years to pay us back
yeah
um or maybe even like a five percent hit
to pay us back so all fish all profit
made off fish
there'll be five percent of it will go
straight into the the united nations
fund yeah
for the following nine years and that
will replenish the fund
and then we can pay you for that year
yeah so you man gonna make all of you
gonna make five percent
less money but you're gonna have jobs
forever yeah
the year you have off you're gonna get
paid for it basically i've hired
i've literally just sold i've saved the
world in the last 30 seconds yeah
that's an iv these men need to hire me
i've solved it that's you solved it it
sounds like a great idea yeah it only
sounds like a great addict i know [ __ ]
all about deficiencies oh
from the logistics yeah these men were
how are you supposed to do that because
this is
[ __ ] though that's your job
absolutely
i'm the creative guy i spew out the
ideas and you figure all the [ __ ] out
you put it together yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but i need to watch that
though bro yes this is
crazy um right so we've got
um one's gotta go now right now this
week's
one's gotta go is based on food and
drink
um so the first one and this is all
forms right
so drink rice pasta bread
potatoes rice pasta bread and potatoes
wow one's got to go so we're talking
like
pasta is pasta's my life
bread is there potatoes bro chips bro
this is a hard one that's really hard
because i love oh man i love all of that
i love carbs rice
from tattoo that sausage rice there's a
chinese near me that does a roast duck
fried rice i bet that's banging always
[ __ ] sagging
anything rose duck is banging it's
banging fam
i eat rice every day i love nando's
spicy rice
just it's just a humble basic thing
yeah um i think i'll get rid of bread
okay why because i [ __ ] hate how much
bread i eat
okay and i just wanna i just the first
thing whenever i'm thinking i want to
eat cleaner
usually one of the first things i cut
out is bread because it sits on you he
sits on you stodgy and it's just like
man [ __ ] bro i've not had bread in
two and a half weeks gang i bet you feel
fantastic for it
but i hate bread pasta the devil but
i'll never get it i would never
i can eat pasta every day 100 i have
eaten pasta every day
lots of times you have yeah and i was
never vex about it yeah
i love pasta [ __ ] i love pasta
all right cool yeah bread's got to go
all right so oreos
hmm custard creams chocolate digestives
okay and shortbread
your face your face
your okay that's hilarious
stop it stop it okay that's actually
tricky
the funny thing is when i was writing
these ones i was that when i was writing
these ones down i was thinking
now these aren't that great but i like
the way you're thinking about it okay
oreos custard creams chocolate
digestives
and shortbread shortbread is a premium
biscuit
bro premium baby shortbread whoever
invented shortbread would
work for the royal family 100 100 but
for the royal family it is a
premium biscuit that snap and crumble
nah it's exquisite you don't just buy
that yeah you feel bougie when you have
it
just buy it you can't just go shopping
shortbread isn't just something you have
laying around the house
it's a special occasion bro when they do
tesco's tesco's finest with the
chocolate chip ones if you had that
chocolate chip shortbread no tesco's
finest no
big man okay it's so banging okay it's
banging i'll give that a go
right uh i'm actually gonna get rid of
chocolate digestive why
because out of that lineup it's just not
carrying its weight okay and when
probably because my when you said
chocolate digestive my first
thought immediately went to chocolate
hobnobs
okay which i was like oh banging and
then i realized oh no it's not hot
numbers it's a digestive and i was like
[ __ ] that
um okay because our chocolate hobnob in
terms of like visually is exactly the
same as the chocolate digestive yeah but
hobnobs are a million times better
it's the barley and the wheat you get
from the hog is different
it's the textures it's different the
barley
broth the barley and the hobnob is a
gangster hop knobs are different yeah
yeah yeah yeah so yeah digestive [ __ ]
off
all right all right doritos
walkers okay quavers pringles
again all flavors yeah quavers can go
why i love quavers quavers is like
quavers
to be fair i don't really [ __ ] with
chris that much okay
i do like myself some doritos you do and
i do like myself so what was the last
one again pringles
i do like pringles um
walkers is more like a childhood
like standard so i can [ __ ] with walkers
i guess
um i actually really like the baked
walkers at the minute
i don't think i'll try those they're
good i like them a lot
they're a bit more pringly okay um
but i don't know quavers are they're
sawdust i love quavers bro
they're literally made of sawdust so
yeah quivers i don't i don't think i've
ever had a full bag of quavers in my
life bro there was a time
where i i think this was probably
pre-first lockdown
i was buying meal deals galore for lunch
and stuff
i'd always get this pretty much around
like the same two or three wraps i'd
always get quavers
and always get i don't know like right
bean oil but i'd always buy quavers
i love quavers really i love that's
interesting i don't know why i just love
that
i'm the opposite yeah i don't i just
don't give a [ __ ] about cuellar this is
half quavers
fair play all right next one kitkat okay
kitkat chunky let's go kick it okay yeah
yeah
twix okay snickers mars
your face bro kit kat chunky
twix snickers and mars by the way have
you ever had
twix white and the snickers white
no they're sexy bro are they they're
sexy some rich
they're sexy they'd say snickers white
you know sexy
why anyway yeah kitkat chunky twix
snickers oh
when i was a kid i used to [ __ ] hate
snickers
why just some nutty chocolate like move
that from me
i don't want some nuts in my chocolate
yeah when i'm a kid i know what you want
chocolate chocolate yeah you don't want
any
you don't want anything healthy in
chocolate yeah i want everything [ __ ]
um twix is one of them ones where i
never buy but when i'm in the mood to
buy it it's the only thing that will
satisfy me
um two weeks is probably there was this
time in my life twix was my favorite
chocolate ever really hands down
yeah when i was a kid mars used to be my
favorite mars is good
mars gets spicy in your throat though if
you eat too much mars like your throat
gets so how much is too much
i don't know would you be too much to be
fair even if i get like a double if i
get you know the doubles yeah yeah
if i eat all of that in one sitting my
throat will be sore to be fair if i get
a double
mars i would eat the first bit and i'll
probably save it a second bit for a
little later
fold it over yeah yeah ever but a twix
double duo
it's called the long twix back dab
same but i can tell what you're saying
about the mars thing yeah yeah yeah i
always save the second half
but i am excited for a little bit much
yeah much yeah i like to eat the first
half
like at room temp and then i fold it
over and put the second half in the
fridge
oh it gets good to me bro i get excited
um
that's hilarious kitkat chunky though
bro i remember the first ever time i had
a kitkat chunky
i don't but i i love but they first
dropped
and i was like damn because the the
outer layer is a bit thicker
it actually gives you worth the wafer
it's not just a coating it's like a
thick bit
yeah yeah yeah i love a kitchen i never
[ __ ] buy it
but i do love it hmm i want to buy one
today
that's good [ __ ] cat chunky twix
snickers and mars it's probably the
longest you've thought
yeah maybe mars might go actually why
because i do love mars but exactly what
i just said like i just wouldn't back a
double in a sit-in
all of the others i would just smash
that junkie i could probably three in
one scene
twix again gone gone yeah uh snickers i
love snickers now
as a kid i hated it thick as a staple
yeah but yeah mars can go
okay but mars to me now just seems like
a snickers without the nuts
even though i know it's completely
different i know what you mean it just
feels like it's missing something
i know what you mean all right cool last
but not least skittles
starburst fruit pastels
yeah frutella
frutella is the best sweet going it's
top there
in it it's the best starburst style vex
when they look at frutella
it's actual fruit and fruit so you can
taste the fruit if you tell it it makes
no sense bro it tastes like it was
freshly picked
literally the berries and they just put
it in the thing mix that with
the gluten and just wrapped it wrapped
it and gave it to you
bro i love frutella it's juicy it
actually is it's
juicy oh starbucks just tastes
artificial in comparison i can
i can understand that when you compare
it to fruitella yes yeah
um so what was the ones again skittles
all flavors obviously and fruit pastels
i love fruit pastels around you free
pastels bro
with that icing sugar glaze what
is it it's like a sweet krispy kreme
it's basically a krispy kreme
yeah it's great oh it is great okay
okay um
strangely enough i think skittles might
go okay why i do like skittles
but so stupid
i have negative thoughts about skittles
because i used to always try and flick
up and catch them in my mouth
and if they catch you on your tooth you
think the tooth's gone yeah
you think your tooth is gone so that's
the reason why you're juicing
that's the reason skills can [ __ ] off
but now i think as well for skittles is
like um
again you know what i said about the
mars makes your throat spicy i feel that
way
skills when you eat a lot of skills if
you get like a mouthful of skittles
after you've got all this like grainy
[ __ ] in your mouth and it
lingers and it's a bit it's not like
it's not great i do love skittles
i love like skittles shots as well nice
yeah they're tasty bro
yeah skittle bombs skittle bombs
but yeah i think skills have to go
because in the other words like
starburst i love
it's no frutella but i do love it fruity
obviously
banging and fruit pastels oh they bring
me back to my childhood
my mom used to bring me back some from
workshops she used to work my mom used
to work at a train station
at this like little dingy cafe in the
train station
and when she was just feeling generous
she'd come home and i recognized
the bag that they had like the carrier
bag that they used in that shop
so if she'd ever come home with the bag
i'm like you know
i know there's something in there for me
i just know it yeah yeah
and then she'd give me a packet of fruit
pastels and i was gassed that's good
that was i was so gassed and she usually
make me share with my brother
she would like snap it like that and
then just give us half of it
that's good but yeah bro oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
well you ever wanted when you eat
skittles where you ever want to
eat them individually just grab a load
eat
individual colors like have four reds
and eat the reds four yellows either
sometimes i used to mix it up
i used to like when i was when i was in
like a savory mood
i would put one and suck it until it
gets soft and then eat it and that's
nice
okay with the skittle um but yeah i
never used to do that much
i used to i think i used to just do it
but with jelly beans
i'm meticulously if you get me some
jelly bellies i'm meticulous with it
okay like i like if i'm at home
i'll pour them all out into a bowl and
i'll separate them all into their
separate colors and then i'm just
they're like
which one should i go for yeah and
there's a very cherry
or maybe a lemon and lime i'm not sure
and i'll sit there and deliberate
that is hilarious i think i only ever do
that in terms of skills
in terms of eating like the individual
flavors as opposed to a whole mouthful
i did that when when they were dropping
like the sour ones the this ones and
that ones
i would do it so i can taste the
individual yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
actually
nice blah blah but as a whole generic
sweet i would just back them
yeah but when they drop the individual
flavors or the different flavors rather
i'll back them individually
taste they used to get like i love the
sauce you've used to get the sour
chewetts
the fat tings had a dinosaur on the
front
maybe yes yes and then that is a
metallic raffle yes yes
they were sad they were fat as well
is like in between starbursts and
frutella i know what you mean yeah i
know exactly
i know exactly what you mean i know
exactly what you mean bro
it's literally they're so chewy yeah
they are
it makes like they stick to my back of
my teeth yeah
wall at their time same you can't back
them multiple like when you buy free
turf free passes or starbucks
because it just gets so much for you
yeah right now you mean but yeah
okay so your last your the ones that are
going are bread
chocolate digestives quavers mars and
skittles
okay guys let me know which ones you
chose at home perfect right
am i the [ __ ] to finish the also
let's go
i have a dilemma slash am i the [ __ ]
slash am i just [ __ ] cool right so
backstory about a year ago
i started talking to this girl
light-skinned mulan vibes
mulan vibes you know you need to show me
a picture yeah
you can't just drop that in there you
should drop a picture a liar yeah yeah
yeah
i caught feelings quick obviously yeah
if it's move
because we are legit the same level of
goofy stroke crackhead
and just have that synergy dang sin it
might say
synergy i haven't heard that in a minute
yeah yeah i don't think i've ever used
that in a sentence
neither were that right um long story
short things fell apart after about two
months
she met someone else lied to me and
broke things off
i was blocked and then unblocked three
weeks later
i guess things didn't work out sucker
bro when you get unblocked by a girl
it's
it's a sticky area it is it's a sticky
area to be in
it is um we then became on and off for
the next year not meeting up because
something always came up on her part
problem
more or less a year later we've planned
an official date am i an [ __ ] for
wanting to cancel
most probably gonna cancel because i'm
realizing this isn't gonna go anywhere
as i'm getting major deja vu vibes from
last year
she seems excited for the date though um
she lives in leicester i live in
southampton
i'm in leicester quite a lot though yeah
it is a trek um
yeah so um i don't think he's an [ __ ]
for once council it also depends on
where the date is because if you are in
southampton and the date is in leicester
because i'm
the way she's the way you are going on
about how she always has an excuse
during the previous year for you wanting
to link up and stuff
i can guarantee you she ain't coming to
him you're always the one trying to do
the move
so one i don't think it's worth your
time considering she
you guys had the same synergy whatever
and then she
found the next thing blocked to you and
then unblocked you
she's not thinking about you she thinks
about [ __ ] she's thinking about herself
yeah and what benefits her so that's why
she unblocked yeah and who's around
as and when you know what i mean do
yourself a favor son
and just ignore just done the whole
dance it's not worth it because you're
you're better than that bro
in my opinion you're better than that
man yeah you're not second best no one
should be
no one should be second best in anyone's
relationship you know yeah anyone's idea
of a relationship so just
yeah no ting could could start could no
there's no girl that could be talking to
me then start talking to someone else
and block me
and then when she's done with that
unblock me and start talking to me again
no bro
no bro you have what do i look like you
have to have some form of dignity
yeah some form of self take pride in
yourself right man it's not
there's always going to be girls out
there but a lot of the time because it's
someone you've been fixated on the
synergy like you said you guys are good
energy banter blah blah blah blah blah
blah
vibes like you've you've put her on a
pedal store yeah
you've just got a pedestal bro from and
that's
your fault from the jump um and it sucks
because
you you guys had the same synergy or
whatever but then she blocked you
and then she unblocked that that in
itself is a clear-cut sign that she's
not here for you
yeah she's not benefiting yeah she's all
about herself
literally all about herself she didn't
give a [ __ ] about you and it's been time
now bro it's been time you said
a year you guys were on and off and then
the next year the date is
could happen yeah yeah yeah it seems
long worth it
it's not working yeah bro and imagine
you drive all the way up there and she
just pies you off
again she just doesn't respond bro again
no you're vexed bro sound
unless there isn't a normal track yeah
that's the thing as well you're you're
right when you said it's not going to go
anywhere yeah it can't it can't
it's not going to go anywhere so you
might as well not just lock it off now
it's not normal
like when we lived in cod for me to even
go to leicester sometimes i couldn't be
bothered
same same same so if you'd say
that change at an uneaten or whatever it
was
long long bro i can't even take a quick
nap yeah you have to be alert for the
changeover
yeah i mean you had to sit there for
like half an hour in the cold in there
man
station was dead there's one of those
trains worst trains
bro they stopped every five minutes oh
bro it's not worth it yeah i think you
already knew the answer
but i think you just wanted that
confirmation from the mandem but trust
me you know
you know it's not worth it she's not
worth i don't think anyone is worth
especially
it would have been different if you both
have other things going on like you
you both wanted a link but obviously yes
the distance was an issue you had things
following you she had ting solomon her
so the vibe just wasn't there but the
fact that you both said you had synergy
you were
in my eyes you're feeling her more than
she's feeding you because she's pied you
off more than once yeah bro more than
twice more doesn't rate you at all
so you need to have some self decency
self dignity rather than some pride and
be like
i know i fancy this girl i know she's
mulan vibes
but she can't get the better of me i
need to lock her off and when you do
that trust me you'll feel ten times
better
because that's when you feel like okay i
can chase off a ting star or i can start
moving to other things down yeah man
not to sit not to say that you haven't
been doing that but she can't be the
forefront at all bro
at all because once you lock her up
she's gonna be like oh he's actually got
some balls yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's not the doormat i thought he
was a doormat wow
just wipes her feet when she's ready to
come in bro
no ma'am it's not worth it i think
that's an opener shot case i think you
knew the answer before you sent it to us
like i said you just wanted a
confirmation from the mandem
um but yeah that's it all right guys
signing off signing off we'll see you
next week i hope you have a great week
guys and yeah
[Music]
gang
you